[Music]
every one I've got another quick
footnote for you between chapters today
when I've talked about linear
transformation so far I've only really
talked about transformations from 2d
vectors to other 2d vectors represented
with two by two matrices or from 3d
vectors to other 3d vectors represented
with three by three matrices but several
commenters have asked about non square
matrices so I thought I'd take a moment
to just show what those mean
geometrically by now in the series you
actually have most of the background you
need to start pondering a question like
this on your own but I'll start talking
through it just to give a little mental
momentum it's perfectly reasonable to
talk about transformations between
dimensions such as one that takes 2d
vector z-- to 3d vectors again what
makes one of these linear is that grid
lines remain parallel and evenly spaced
and that the origin maps to the origin
what I have pictured here is the input
space on the Left which is just 2d space
and the output of the transformation
shown on the right
the reason I'm not showing the inputs
move over to the outputs like I usually
do is not just animation laziness it's
worth emphasizing that 2d vector inputs
are very different animals from these 3d
vector outputs living in a completely
separate unconnected space encoding one
of these transformations with a matrix
is really just the same thing as what
we've done before you look at where each
basis vector lands and write the
coordinates of the landing spots as the
columns of a matrix for example what
you're looking at here is an output of a
transformation that takes I hat to the
coordinates 2 negative 1 negative 2 and
J hat to the coordinates 0 1 1
notice this means the matrix encoding
our transformation has three rows and
two columns which to use standard
terminology makes it a three by two
matrix in the language of last video the
column space of this matrix the place
where all the vectors land is a 2d plane
slicing through the origin of 3d space
but the matrix is still full rank since
the number of dimensions in this column
space is the same as the number of
dimensions of the input space so if you
see a three by two matrix out in the
wild you can know that it has the
geometric interpretation of mapping two
dimensions to three dimensions since the
two columns indicate that the input
space has two basis vectors and the
three rows indicate that the landing
spots for each of those basis vectors is
described with three separate
coordinates likewise if you see a 2 by 3
matrix with 2 rows and 3 columns what do
you think that means well the three
columns indicate that you're starting in
a space that has three basis vectors so
we're starting in three dimensions and
the two rows indicate that the landing
spot for each of those three basis
vectors is described with only two
coordinates so they must be landing in
two dimensions so it's a transformation
from 3d space onto the 2d plane a
transformation that should feel very
uncomfortable if you imagine going
through it
you could also have a transformation
from two dimensions to one dimension one
dimensional space is really just the
number line so transformation like this
takes in 2d vectors and spits out
numbers thinking about grid lines
remaining parallel unevenly spaced is a
little bit messy due to all of the
squish off' occation happening here so
in this case the visual understanding
for what linearity means is that if you
have a line of evenly spaced dots it
would remain evenly spaced once they're
mapped onto the number line one of these
transformations is encoded with a 1 by 2
matrix each of whose two columns has
just a single entry the two columns
represent where the basis vectors land
and each one of those columns requires
just one number the number that that
basis vector landed on this is actually
a surprisingly meaningful type of
transformation with close ties to the
dot product and I'll be talking about
that next video until then I encourage
you to play around with this idea on
your own contemplating the meanings of
things like matrix multiplication and
linear systems of equations in the
context of transformations between
different dimensions have fun
[Music]
you